so
hi everyone my name is etienne bernard
and i work at war from research
basically
i'm leading the machine learning group
there
and today i'm going to talk about the
the functions the
tools that we've been building over the
last years
uh i mean i'm gonna be quickly talking
about what we before i'm gonna be mostly
talking about what we're adding to this
uh
to the next version which is 12.2 that
should be there in
a matter of months i guess and uh
and then talk also a bit about our plan
um
about what to do in the in the in the
future
and uh and about that i would be very
happy
if you give me your you know your your
comments
your your opinions about what we should
do um
that would be great if you have some
specific needs uh in what you're doing
uh that help us to prioritize like we
have a big list of things but
that helps us to prioritize one thing
over another so in the world from
language
uh there's usually you can decompose the
thing we
have in terms of machine learning in
three parts one part
is this what i call the high level
machine learning or automatic machine
learning sometimes we call it
uh which is a bunch of functions that
are very task oriented um
for example the main one is classify
classifier you give it a list of
examples that are that are labeled
like you know it's an image and this is
a tag it's a griffin this is an image
and the tag is dragon
an image and the or the class i rather
say
is cento in that case and uh you just
run classify on this set of examples
there's a bunch that i'm missing by the
way there's like 20 more here or
something like that
um you don't have to specify the method
you know let's specify the
pre-processing it figures these things
by itself
and and then you can use that to
classify new
new images and more generally new
example doesn't have to be image it's
all sort of things it's audio
text and a bunch of numbers categorical
variables a mix
of all these things and as you will see
we
we added a graph time series uh recently
another function to predict a number
instead of a class there's functions to
learn the distribution of data
and uh so it's unsupervised learning
function
and you can you can do you know
synthesizing missing values with that
detecting anomalies
this function to clusters to close to
find clusters in data
and dimension reduction so this is a bit
similar to learn distribution is to to
find a a
reduced representation of each of the
[Music]
two yeah of the example in a way to find
the manifold on which the data lies
okay that's that's the high-level
machine learning part
and then we have a lower level which is
our neural network framework
and so this this you you need to specify
the model yourself contrary to this
where you can just run the function here
you need to create the model
or use a model that already exists such
as here here it's
using a net model um
and then you can modify it to to so it
suits your
your your applications uh it's very
classic by the way when you're doing
neural networks you just take a nail
that you only talk that already exists
changing usually the end of the network
just to make it satisfy you know
whatever constraints you
you have and uh and then training it on
your data
and uh so that's the simplest training
we can imagine
it's just it's just a linear layout the
simplest neural network you can do
and so there's still some automation in
the sense that
here the optimization method is not
specified
or the the batch size or all these
things learning rate is not specified
you can't specify them but but there's a
bit of automation but still it's more
low level than the high level machine
learning functions
all right so and and last thing is the
application that we do
with uh with these tools so for example
image cases something that finds
objects and classify them in the image
or
text cases so here it says find all the
city country and date and return
the string the interpretation as
as an entity and your your confidence
in a way that that it is uh indeed uh
sitting a country or a date and uh and i
would do
that would do the job and then there's a
bunch of net model that i talked already
uh like uh excuse me
like if i do actually probably we can
see a bunch
[Music]
exactly so you can see there's a big
list oh it's
behind the screen
uh yeah exactly
so there's many pre-trained networks
some of them that we just imported
some of them that we train ourselves and
uh
that you can use like that's that's the
network of
email.c5 for example um
okay which looks like
like this
you can note that we also changed a
little bit how the
the layers look i don't have the latest
version so i think it changed a little
bit but
uh now when it's square it means that
there's some
learnable parameter inside and when it's
round it means there's no learn
parameter
and then also the icon changed also
let's see if we find one
no they're all the same anyway you'll
see but when
when it's a layer that contains other
layer the the
border is bold and uh i mean we'll see
examples
actually we can see them here here the
border is bold because they are new
they are you know
exactly there's another thing inside and
in that one as well
there's another graph inside but here
there's nothing inside so it's not
it's kind of the leaf of this sort of of
of tree
of of of layers um
all right cool let's see the questions
already uh
can you go into visualization tools uh
i guess that's what i just did and uh
and yes i will upload the notebook at
the end for sure
for sure uh i don't have time to do it
right now maybe i should have done it
before but
okay so what's new in high level machine
learning
uh one thing that is new is that when
you use classifier measurements
instead of this object that is not super
informative
uh it returns a nice report so you can
kind of see usually what you want
in this report without needing to to
query this measurement
object for for extra properties uh so
just to recall classifier measurements
you give the classifier the first
argument and the test set a second
argument and it evaluates the classifier
on the test set and compute a bunch of
of measures um so this is a report but
it's actually computable
thing so you can use this report to to
ask for the accuracy
and a bunch of other properties not just
the properties that you see here
this is really just for display you
actually have a lot of properties you
can ask
this report and you have the same thing
for predictor measurements
okay
and uh all right
just checking if anyone raised the hand
um
okay other thing that's that i think
many people will like
uh it's measurements from predictions
uh because in the past the first
argument had to be a classifier
but now it can just be let's say the
classification in that case the classes
that are that are predicted by the by
the classifier
and this is still test set i don't need
the input though because i i just need
to compare with the output but i mean
you can put the input if you want but
it's not necessary anymore and here i
can compute the accuracy between these
two
two sets basically and i can also have
the report as we absolutely saw before
you can also give the probabilities for
each class
and uh and in that case it will also
compute probabilistic metrics
such as here mean cross-entropy
and you can also give that as a
categorical distribution
uh this is a type of distribution that
we added
um in the 12.1 i believe
i don't know if you're familiar with it
and
yeah so that's uh and the nice thing is
that it doesn't have to be a classifier
or a neural network
uh the first argument so so you can have
your custom
classifier and you can still do all
these measures easily
um and same thing for
for predict so you can do predictor
measurements these are the predictions
these are the real values and that's the
that's the report and
again you can put instead of the
prediction as a unique prediction you
can put a prediction as
a distribution
and uh and it will also compute things
like
cross-entropy which is a probabilistic
measures measure okay
see if there's any question about that i
cannot tape
[Music]
so how can we extract from decision tree
algorithm learned by classify
i see so you cannot but
we are we are thinking of having a
function that is just for that
classified also as a bunch of
preprocessors like there's a bunch of
things going on
in this so it's no longer be like a nice
decision tree that you can extract from
a classifier function
but we are doing a function that will
just restrict itself to just the
decision tree
because we know that that can be a nice
way to to to have an interpretable model
in some cases it's useful uh that's
something we are we are
we are actually thinking a lot
i mean it will be there soon i think
um to create the compile function from
the trend yes
and we will see that right after uh can
i deploy the net train function for
particular net architecture
in order to have a c function that can
train
basically yes although you have to do a
bit of work like we
will talk about it after we we have an
exporter to on nx which is kind of an
exchange format for networks
and um and from there
there's a lot of tools to convert this
onyx uh
network to various things and and you
know what i bet there's something to
to to to to convert to a c function but
you know you can convert to many many
many things um
okay so
next thing probability calibration
um that's something that was
close to my heart and i finally did it
uh not that the story is that
interesting
uh okay so let's train a network and
here i use an internal option
you know you don't have to really care
about that uh i just
prevents the model from being calibrated
and here i'm going to compute the to
visualize a reliability diagram
also known as a calibration curve
and on x-axis you have the predicted
probability on the right on the on the
y-axis the actual probability
so this means that let's say this point
this means that we gathered all the
every time the classifier predicted 60
of chance let's say it's around the area
60 of chance of being a given class
okay uh so each time the classifier says
i believe it's sixty percent of chance
of being whatever class
and then we looked among all this
example that says sixty percent
when was the classifier right and
apparently it was right 99
of the time so this being that this
classifier was seriously underconfident
seriously underconfident and and you can
have the opposite where classifier is
completely over continent what
you're going to say well i believe it's
the right class with 99 of chance
and actually you realize that among all
these times it says 99
well it's only 80 let's say or 50
uh usually they're more i mean when you
have a neural network for example they
are typically overconfident and not
under confident but is the case where
it's under confident
and so and so yeah you can have a
diagnostic
with this reliability diagram which by
the way
if you look in other libraries it's
usually
what i call now the classic reliable
diagram that i don't like so much
uh is just the probabilities are between
it's it's a flat scale it's a linear
scale
you know we can zero and one and uh and
you have these
s-curves and so on but if you if you
have in in sort of logic scale uh
where you know like the thing close to
zero expanded and think close to when i
expand it as well
it's much nicer to visualize i think it
is usually a straight line
um and here you cannot really see what's
going on here and
and here i mean that case nothing's
happening here but
right so now let's um
train without this option and you'll see
that automatically classify
calibrates its its result
so we also added that now not for all
method but
all the oh actually not that great but
still it's much better
now you see it's much closer to the to
the line perfect calibration line
so here it was like 90
of belief and the result was maybe 80
you know 80 something 89 or something
uh so
now classifier is better calibrated
which i think is an important
important thing okay um sharp values
um so this is something to to i mean
this is just a starts it's very
experimental
it's something to explain the decision
of uh the predictors and the classifiers
and uh here i'm going to get a data set
predict the one quality as function of
all these features
and
and then predict the quality of this
wine which by the way was 6 but it's
going to be ignored and it pricked 5.6
and then i'm going to ask why was it six
and this gives a bunch of number and
basically says well the acidity
contributes uh kind of like the
you know there's a mean prediction of
all the examples and it says well that
there's a
the acidity contributes negatively
of 0.11 0.12 um
to to the prediction and if you sum all
these values
and you add the mean it will give this
prediction of five and six
and uh i'm not going to talk further
because jesse is talking about it so he
can explain to you how this works
um okay and uh but as i was saying
it's just the beginning in this area uh
we hope to have
more things later graph features so
before you couldn't put graph into
machining functions
and then you can so here's an example of
feature space plots i just created
random graph from various
graph distributions and uh and you can
see that it correctly
uh kind of separated the the graph
depending on on their
on the nature so to speak on yeah these
are bernoulli graph
barabasi graph and uniform graph and i
can do the same thing with with
classifier
so here i label them let's say this is a
bunch of bernodilly graph a bunch of bar
busy a bunch of uniform
and and then it can predict uh which one
it is
which by the way for this example is
pretty easy i should i should
i should make it a bit harder but this
is pretty
pretty easy to have a classifier for
that um
so yeah so you can use that i don't know
maybe for for molecules i mean you need
to do a little bit of processing
maybe next time we should add molecule
as a type as well
uh and you can do that for a bunch of
other of the
other other applications uh
time series also we added some some
feature extraction
and therefore feature let's say
understanding for for time series
so that's just an example of feature
space plot uh
and uh yeah by the way the way it works
is it does a bunch compute a bunch of
properties about the
the the the graph so things like
actually i can probably show you
now if we dig in the inside of the
classifier
i can show you what it does
which graph extract features yep yep yep
so you see it compute you know some
classic properties such as is it
directed is it a multi graph is it
empty graph is it weighted is it blah
blah blah blah blah and then a bunch of
numeric properties
vertex counts graph density graph
reprocessity
and so on and and also some statistics
about the
connectivity of each node like if they
have a lot of edges or not
so you know quantiles of this of this
list of of let's say edge count
and uh and things like that so it's a
bunch of of statistics
um so it's not like it's a neural
network that is you know
learning a nice representation for the
graph which
theoretically is possible but you have
to have many many more graphs
uh so this is kind of a sort of brute
force approach that
actually i find already efficient and we
did kind of the same thing for time
series
so it computes you know a bunch of
fourier transform a bunch
bunch of of things you know detect the
peaks and things like that
uh and make features out of all this
this uh
these measures and i think it's already
going to be pretty useful for a bunch of
applications
okay let's see there's some some some
questions
on x refer to train net yes c function
that i can fit learning data that will
return the weight
uh uh no no no no this this
uh definitely not you need to train with
the wolfram language okay can you
discuss support for fitting classifiers
two training sets with badly imbalanced
class numbers
huh that's interesting that's something
that classifies not very good at that
currently
uh so we have to do something about it
um
basically the trick is to reduce the
dimension so
i mean if you want to do it by yourself
right now what i would do
is you take your data and you first you
forget about the classes
you just use dimension reduction that we
saw in the beginning
oops dimension reduction to find a small
representation and then you train on
that
and i would avoid the example that have
a small number of
of somebody talk to me
let's see on the chat
okay um and and that would avoid
uh the class that has a small number of
examples to kind of overfit
you can also learn the distribution like
the extreme version is like for anomaly
detection where you learn the
distribution
of the input and you just use the pdf as
a feature
for classification so it's kind of
extreme dimensionality reduction
um so that's things you can do for
extremely balanced
uh classes and hopefully we can
integrate these sort of things into
classify soon
that's a good point um okay
let's see some other questions and uh
yep so classified technique
yeah so this is
that's interesting titanic i guess so
usually on small
data sets it tends to to change uh
it's it's uh the method that it uses
uh it is fundamentally stochastic the
way it searches for the best method
so one one thing to to make it more
consistent and better is just to
increase
the sort of search time so you can use
tango
you can use the option time goal to to
tell classify so
let's look in the documentation
and then you can tell classify well
spend a long time to do your business
which for that case is not really useful
but
uh and then it will do much more search
it will try many more methods many more
uh hyper parameters and so on
and uh and find and find a good
classifier and uh
and in that case it should be more
consistent i expect that it's because it
has a small
um like by default it's a little bit
aggressive on time
i can also put performance goal to
quality to to to alleviate that but
yeah i think by default it's a little
bit aggressive on the time and that's
why you have different especially on
smoke that i said
uh i mean small data set you also have
the fact that you don't have enough
examples uh
okay so uh then you have we have new
methods
uh that i won't go in detail about it is
something about classified this is a
two method for dimension reduction this
one multi-dimensional scaling is pretty
well known
and probably we should have done that
before but anyway it's there
dimension reduce and that's an example
of multi-dimensional scaling it's
extremely classic it's just
try to preserve the distances that's it
that's that's only thing that this thing
is doing is
you have an original space high
dimensional and you
embed all this data in the low
dimensional space and try to have the
distance between each pairs be the same
in the feature space than in the
original space
so extremely simple and works pretty
well
so okay now let's
change move to the neo network framework
and
uh so onyx exports which is super useful
to uh you know deploy your neural
networks
let's say on on a cell phone which is
what joffrey did and he's going to talk
about it
today so
and uh i won't spoil it but
the idea is is you you you expand to
onyx and then from onyx
either you use the onyx runtime um
that that many device supports or you
convert to kind of
the specific format that that
given device wants such as core ml for
for an iphone
function layer there's going to be a
talk about it as well so i'm not going
to talk it too much
i'm going to talk about it today and but
basically it's a way to put
regular word from language code to
construct layers so it can be a very
simple code like just a function
min and that's an example or it can be a
more complex function
and in that case you see this is a just
a vector
of numbers that are fixed right and this
is a vector of numbers but that is
learnable that's just the initial values
so that's a learnable array and that's a
new thing as well net array that we
constructed four function layer
and so you can create
arbitrary layers like that and uh
see how it looks you can see the
function you can see the graph so this
is
compiling to our neural network
uh framework all right so it's doing a
sort of conversion
to to a graph that's how it works which
means that it's limited to static
computation
uh computation graph uh you can have a
you cannot have if statement for example
which 499 percent application is not not
an issue
basically the so yeah everything you can
do here you could do it with a graph
but often for many applications it's
nicer to write it as code
than as a graph for example to share
layers
for sharing layers it's much nicer to to
use regular code
um all right compile layer
very related material is going to talk
about it um
it's it's you you basically we leverage
the new compiler for the wolfram
language which is function compile and
uh
where you create a function and you have
to specify the type
very well uh you know that's the rank of
the array the type of the
of the data and so on then you put your
function
and then you can do compile layer and
just use it and this
is not compiling to our framework this
is really
keeping it as easy so i think it's
convert to lvm first
so it's going to be slower of course but
you have more freedom and for example
you can have if statements
uh if you want although at the moment
the output shape is fixed
so so it's not absolutely
let's say universal we start working on
adding new array processing functions
it's not really machine learning per se
but
since we start to define networks with
regular code uh it's necessary to have
really good array processing function to
to to write this these networks
so the first one we did was error reduce
which is kind of a way to
perform an operation like min on on
whatever axis that you want
here it will perform on the on the
on the rows actually
and uh i think if you do that it's on
the on the column exactly
uh okay that's a little explanation of
what it does let's not go into the
detail
you can also do a many axes it's like
aggregation layer for for the one that
knows in the neural network world
um okay new new function okay maybe
let's not
uh okay this is just new layer you can
check them out
and a bunch of new net models that you
can check on the website
i see we already the time has already
passed i guess we started a bit late
so let me look a little bit of the
question and then we'll go about what's
next
um if i randomly split data 80 like 2080
and then when classified a classifier
function if i put i have one read
function how can i combine the function
into a single composite function
well my guess is you compute the
probabilities
and then you do a geometric mean of the
probabilities
that's what i would do it's just a very
simple way to combine classifier
functions
uh there's no way there's no built-in
way
i think actually there is one but it's a
bit hacky um
so i'm not going to talk about it
okay so what's next uh
in the high level world we just started
to
to to to explore and and build things
in the domain of model and decision
explanations so the most famous alarm
shop
so shop you see is the first sort of
quite experimental version that that you
will have in 12.2
uh i must say that still not the
stimulus does the perfect thing like we
have to uh
which is yeah for some reason that
that jesse probably will explain uh
virtual example counterfactual sort of
things you know like
give me an example that give a decent
decision but it's not too far from
uh the original example and this is give
me one that is also realistic give me a
realistic example that is
that gives that would have given another
decision that is close to my current
example
we need to automate more dimension
prediction and clustering in the same
way as we do for classify or learn
distribution
it's kind of a different automation
procedure and
this one is i mean classify and learn
distribution are superior
about that reinforcement learning that's
something that would be
really nice there's not that many
applications to be honest but
that would be pretty cool to have it
nevertheless maybe something called
policy optimize i don't know
also detection function that's something
we need to get into i think
it's basically you know inside the time
series find your anomalies or inside an
image find objects and you need to learn
from data how to do that and uh so you
know classify just classifying one thing
and here it's more and then there's a
bunch of functions uh
i mean of task uh which is just fine
inside the text or
or image or sounds or time series and
find stuff
in in inside these things
then phone you will net extension or
function layer
of course like probably this is going to
be and
i think when it's really really good it
might be renamed something like net
function
something like that and to really
program whatever you want
and that's a new network and it will
learn and uh that will be they'll be
super cool that's where we want to go
uh reinforcement learning we'll be
thinking of some tools also to help
maybe just the classic learning methods
will have their function like gradient
policy optimized
uh device object is our way to define an
environment
excel net something to not convert a
network to our framework but just keep
it in its original thing
so for example onyx that would onix
network that would just convert
stay honest network and what's nice
is that there's some network that cannot
be converted to our framework
uh but with that it won't be the case
anymore
and so you can evaluate you might not be
able to train them but you might
at least evaluate them um in front of
them um
and also on any device uh usually the
next runtime will be more
cover more uh device than uh
than our own uh uh inference
engine let's call it uh ending space
rate trigraph
uh training that would be great training
on mac amd
cards uh i mean amd gpu in general which
includes mac
maybe something about training easier on
the cloud that's something
and last thing uh
is we're starting to go a little bit
into what machine learning can do for
statistics and data mining
um so for example you know having
privacy programming that would be
very cool and for people to do buyers
and statistics with that like they kind
of define the experiments
you know in a probabilistic way and then
they can
uh infer you know if this group
is doing better than that group and
automatically do that
imputation and all these sort of things
uh also data relation extraction there
will be something
uh like association rule learning this
is super classic but there's a bunch of
things we're thinking about about
finding relation between features you
know this sort of thing like anything
that is interesting in the data i would
like to be able to extract it and and
tell you about
okay i think that's it and i'm gonna
look at the questions again
and uh when are the new features
expected to be available well
all of that what's new in 12.2 something
like a month
i mean at least that's our current plan
um
and and this one is going to be for the
next version which i think is something
like in april
of 2021
yeah but i don't promise that we'll have
everything uh for
for for this next version
okay i think uh
good i don't see any other questions so
thank you everyone for being here bye